we often think confidence and we think
certainty it's not certainty it's
confidence in knowing what the task is
what the demands are and then what are
your capabilities the capabilities to
know that win lose or draw i can
navigate through this thing
talk to me about your background for
people that aren't familiar with your
work and what you've done in the past
what is your career up to this point
yeah absolutely so um i was a high level
runner so i was a four minute and one
second miler just missed that four
minute barrier growing up so that was
kind of my background went to university
in college
expecting to go entirely the sports
route and be a professional athlete
and i completely bombed i never improved
on my kind of junior best so i quickly
realized oh i have to pay attention to
academics and figure out what in the
world it is i want to do
so i did the logical thing which was
i'm gonna get into coaching so
after university i got into athletic
coaching and track and field and did
that for a very long time um
well for over a decade early on in that
i actually worked for for nike for a
couple years and went through a big
whistle-blowing experience and had to
leave that and then went into
collegiate coaching here in the us and
then
from there i've kind of expanded out
into okay performances performance
yes i want to help people run faster on
the track or
perform better in sport
but you know the same skills that
athletes are utilizing so are executives
so our entrepreneurs so our physicians
and really you know exploring that more
holistically so in the last gosh three
four years i've kind of expanded out to
you know just try to help people perform
better
how much can you talk about the nike
whistleblower
situation
yeah we can go down however far you want
to tell me the story i didn't know about
this
yeah so it actually it actually is funny
because it it started or it exploded in
the uk first actually
uh because it was a bbc program that
kind of broke the story but essentially
what happened was i was working with a
group of professional athletes i was
assistant coach
um for the nike oregon project
and i witnessed in the year and a half i
was there
some things that you know
kind of rang alarm bells so after i was
there i
or after i i was done i went and called
us anti-doping up and said hey here's
what i've witnessed
here was my experience i have no idea on
if this breaks the rules or not
but it seemed kind of sketchy to me and
there was a lot of things like uh
you know
injections of various supplements and
like all sorts of crazy stuff there was
like not blatant like hey here's some
steroids use it
but it was it was shady or uh enough
where there were questions around it
and then usi anti-doping spent gosh
almost nine years investigating it
and then ultimately found that the the
head coach and the doctor there had
uh violated anti-doping rules and they
were they were banned so
i spent again nine years of my life well
i continued working and coaching and
like writing and all that stuff but for
nine years i was
you know at the beck and call of uh
going in to testify
and like do all sorts of you know talk
to
law enforcement and all sorts of crazy
things um as part of that dude that
story is wild
nine years of you constantly being this
sort of whistleblower behind the scenes
is it the nike oregon
project that had
weren't they putting undue pressure on
athletes to lose weight or do some other
stuff
yeah so they were so i also reported
that uh that was you as well it was it
was me and then mary kane and some other
athletes who who really did that um as
well cara goucher who spoke up so
there's a bunch of us on that but like i
you know the story that i can tell you
there and this might get across
that part of it is i remember sitting in
a meeting
with the the head coach after a uh it
was after the world indoor championships
and the athletes we were working with
had all competed
and we were talking about one athlete
who had done really well for herself and
had made the final of the championship
and it was her first international
competition so in my head i'm thinking
like great like they made the final this
is a good step like all that good stuff
and the head coach alberto salazar you
know sits down and he said
essentially he said that athlete was
like
so big that she looked like she could
barely lift her legs and this is a
world-class like distance runner and i
remember being like what this is strange
so i you know i pulled out the the body
fat testing that the nike you know that
they'd done at the lab at nike and i
said well you know according to the
science and data
you know where body fat percentage was i
forget it but it was something like 10
which is incredibly low for a female
it's about the lowest you can go
without you know having any sort of
medical problems
and i remember he just he just turns to
me and says
you know i don't give a damn what the
science says i know what i see with my
eyes like they need to lose weight like
we've got to tell them to lose weight
they're too fat and i'm just sitting
there like
what in the world is like what bizarro
world have i entered so
you know i'm glad that eventually all of
that came out and people like mary kane
and others who spoke forward on their
experience
uh what they had to go through because
it was it was wild
how culpable are athletes
if they are under the jurisdiction of
coaches and doctors that are giving them
certain substances how culpable are they
for
um being popped
for peds down the line
so that's a great question i think
that's one of the under discussed um
aspects of you know anti-doping
performance enhancing drugs is
generally what happens as athlete gets
banned if they test positive and then
they're gone but we forget about the
entourage the coaches the doctors all
around them and often what happens is
these athletes are are young
and almost taken advantage of
because you know especially in sports
olympic sports like athletics
is it's not
it's not like you know
the nfl or nba or or soccer football
where it's like they're making millions
and millions and they're okay
you know most of the athletes are not
making that much
so there's a lot of pressure um to
perform and to you know stay relevant so
you can continue in the sport
so what happens is often
the athletes the power dynamic between
the coach and the athlete is so heavily
skewed
where the coach or whoever in charge
like essentially controls the purse
strings especially in these situations
like where i was in where it was it was
you know supported by a major shoe brand
which you know
gave the athlete the salary
so in situations like this i feel really
bad for athletes because you get in this
environment where it's like you either
do what the coach says or you kind of
your contract is gone and you're
you know you're not making any money
anymore
so what happens is
people comply and then i think also as
coaches doctors take advantage of you
know the fact that these are often young
athletes who are almost like desperate
to perform
so it it's it it seldom is hey here's
some steroids and take it what often it
is is like oh
like i want you to try these supplements
that might be a little sketchy oh you
did that oh i want you to try this you
know
injection that is that that is kind of
legal might not be
a slope of peds it and it just goes down
the you know the rabbit hole and then by
the by that time you're you have an
athlete who's like taking something and
they
they all
often don't realize how they got to that
point that's very interesting i imagine
as well in non-professional sports there
are um
fewer controls
and sort of inner regulations because
it's not being operated quite so much
like a business my housemate back in the
uk is the physio for newcastle falcons
which is a premier league rugby team and
you know rugby is nowhere near the level
of our football soccer for you and even
there there's so many checks and
balances and there's a million people
there's no way that you'll be able to
contain any of this [ __ ] going on
another thing young athletes you've
basically got especially if you're
living on site training on site if you
live and breathe the sport if this is
existentially what you feel connected to
basically the coach is a surrogate
parent and what you want is approval
from them you want praise from them you
want to be told that you're doing well
all this sort of stuff
and then if the parent the surrogate
parent says well you've got to get
stronger you've got to get bigger you've
got to lose weight you've got to take
these drugs you've got to take these
supplements or whatever not only are you
going to say yes probably without
thinking but you're also going to have a
lot of undue trust in someone that
doesn't have the same
level of investment or care that a
parent actually would but
i imagine you know some 16 17 18 year
old phenomenon runner
is going to struggle to distinguish
between the two they're just going to
see parent figure
exactly i think you're spot on there and
i think that you know the other part of
it is these athletes are often so good
so young
so their identity is entirely wrapped
around the sport and that is all that
they know well their peers were you know
off experimenting and figuring out like
what do i actually want to do with my
life these athletes are like you know
i'm great at this sport this is what i'm
good at this is my future like go ahead
so i think that makes it even more where
they're vulnerable yes
because it's like if you fail it's not
oh i failed at running or rugby or
football it is like i am a failure
myself
so that puts it even more where like
you're going to see that coach or
authority figure as the person who you
trust as the parental figure who's going
to
guide you in the right direction
and we know when you do that it's almost
like you have these blinders on and you
you kind of stop seeing reality for
reality and instead you see like
you know this is the person i've
entrusted my future with so
if i want to make it to this promised
land which is my entire world and
identity then i have to go and follow
his directions or path it's going to be
tantamount to destruction right complete
just annihilation of the ego sense of
self everything is completely wrapped up
in that sport yeah it's so interesting
what are your thoughts around
the fact that young athletes as they're
coming through or anybody really that
finds success or obsession with
something young
is both at a competitive advantage but
also a vulnerable a vulnerability
disadvantage so
the fact that they don't know anything
else basically means that they are just
completely blinkers on and focus towards
this one goal that means it's going to
be significantly easier for them to
out-compete the person who knows what
it's like to have a girlfriend knows
what it's like to go out partying with
their friends and take a holiday on a
summer vacation with the lads or the
girls or whatever
but on the flip side there's this
increase in vulnerability do you think
if you can control for the vulnerability
that that
sort of unbelievable focus is an
advantage or are there still some
externalities that are negative that
come out of that as well yeah
so i'll just give you my own life and
then the research as well so as i
mentioned i was i was very much a phenom
i mean when i was uh i don't know 14
years old i was like the
third fastest miler in the country for
my age and then by 18 i was the fastest
uh you know high school miler in the in
in the u.s no way
so i was the phenom who was obsessed
just like you said yep blind blinders on
couldn't see anything else
like high school didn't care about
academics didn't care about going out i
was like running running running
and that in some sense allowed me to be
really really good
because i was going to put in the work
and forget everything else and put track
and running first
and i think that works for a limited
amount of time often but inevitably what
happens is you get confronted with
reality
which is if your entire world is in this
obsession
then inevitably when you face some sort
of struggle or failure or set back
it often pops that bubble
and you're looking around being like i
devoted everything to this
and now i can't even like reach this
goal this goal this goal and that can be
it's almost like
you have an identity crisis when you're
you know you're an adolescent or teen or
like early 20s trying to go through this
so i think
what it is is yes that obsession can be
incredible
but it needs to almost be directed and
have some diversity or constraints set
around it so that you kind of don't lose
your mind yeah
i guess the the alternative or the other
danger that you have is if you start to
introduce this young athlete to other
things you begin to see them become
distracted by those other things so it's
very much a balancing act i guess
between the focus on training the life
being revolved around the sport and the
pursuit but the sense of self sense of
self-worth
that being a little bit more distracted
so
my only equivalent i wasn't as elite as
you but i played county cricket which is
the equivalent of like premier league
cricket all the way through from the age
of 10 till the age of 18 that was all i
did
four five six games a week throughout
all of summer training it was all i
thought about it was all i did took time
out of college our high school to go and
do it and then i had the choice of do
you want to go to university are you
going to make a go of this cricket thing
i didn't think i was a good enough
cricketer to commit to that but as soon
as i went to university i fell in love
with running businesses so i started
running a business at 18 years old and i
i got my great the only reason i even
got into uni is because my grades were
reduced because the director of the
program that i was joining the business
school was in love with cricket and knew
that i was going to come and play for
the university team so i got three b's
at a level it was a
a b to get in and i failed i didn't get
into my first choice and my second
choice the only reason i got it is
because he'd reduced the grade so
cricket literally got me into university
and i don't think about that enough
but
as soon as i got there i sat next to my
business partner in my first ever
seminar
and we started running a business that
day basically we started working
together that very day and i became
obsessed with running a business and
making money and getting success and
claiming status and stuff like that
but that completely destroyed my
sporting career i i didn't want to play
for the first at uni i wanted to play
for the seconds because it meant i had
more time to go to work they played on a
different day which actually worked with
our portfolio of events that we'd
started running and all this other stuff
so i saw in front of my own eyes my
athletic obsession
dissolve
because of other stuff that came through
and if you have
that focus and that obsession previously
you've already got a trained style of
living
and
that can
quickly sort of be moved you applying
the same energy but to a different
pursuit and then the first pursuit that
you had just gets completely fallen away
it's the same reason i think that when
people get out of relationships they've
been in for ages they jump straight into
another one because they just take the
same energy they were working on in the
first relationship remove the partner
but keep going with the same energy
yeah i think you're spot on and i think
that's a great story and then that final
analogy is is wonderful because it
really is where you direct it and i the
way i like to think of it is
it's almost your little superpower to
have this kind of obsession but
the key is like how do we stay in
control of it and keep it in check and
as you said like have just enough space
between our sense of self and this thing
that we do so that it doesn't turn
negative and if you look at actually you
know decades ago there was a wonderful
psychologist ellen winner who did some
research on prodigies you know and like
chess and math and all this stuff
and she she called it beautifully she
said they all have the rage to master
which is that obsession right and it can
be applied to math chess sport business
whatever have you they all have that
rage to master but the difference
between the ones who were able to carry
it through and maybe didn't like fail or
burn out is that that rage to master
came from like this intrinsic place of i
want to do this of this brings me joy
and yes it might be tough and i might go
through struggles but i just love that
process
and that's what it's all about and in
fact um i was talking to american uh
coach tom house who's famous for
coaching american stars like uh
nolan ryan and tom brady and throwing
and he put it he put it this way as like
the greatest of all time like they are
obsessed and in love with that process
it's not necessarily like hey i'm doing
this and obsessed because i want to
you know achieve x y and z outcome it's
that man this energy i'm directing it
towards something and yes if i keep
directing it towards something i'm going
to achieve some great outcome but that's
not the center focus and i think there's
a clear again a clear but subtle
distinguishing line between that and the
way i almost like to think of it as like
maybe the obsession you kind of directed
towards business versus maybe you know
someone like elizabeth holmes
in the us who
was by all accounts obsessed but because
she was so obsessed took that towards
like fraud and cheating because she had
to like have that status and win instead
of being about like the discovery the
exploration the process
in creating what you know something
great how familiar are you with the
stoics and stoicism as a philosophy
uh i mean i'm uh
it's kind of familiar i've read ryan
holiday's work
i'm gonna butcher it and ryan's coming
on the show in a couple of weeks so
he'll tell me off
but there's four stoic virtues i want to
say it's temperance something else
wisdom and something else right
and i'm pretty sure that ryan said that
wisdom is one of the ones that's most
important because it is the one that
ensures that the actions of the other
three are being directed towards
something which is good in and of itself
and this is the difference between
elizabeth holmes and that guy that's
trying to clean up all of the plastic
from the oceans right they both had an
obsession have an obsession
but
one of them was filtering their
momentum
through a effective strategy right
through something that they knew would
be good genuinely good for the world and
you know people can be obsessive
human traffickers or they could be you
know obsessive drug dealers or gang land
bosses mafia bosses and stuff i imagine
that
if you were able to take those skills
and apply them to something legitimate
or altruistic you would have an
unbelievably effective person problem
being that it's just being directed in
the wrong way so i think i think you're
very right there and also to talk about
the fact that a obsession is a
competitive advantage is so so true i
know that you mentioned that you can
become pretty obsessed with stuff and i
think that i do as well and from the
outside looking in it is
there's something kind of romantic about
it but then there's also something kind
of tragic about it as well right that
you're constantly going to play this
battle with yourself this desire for
more this desire to be more effective
this
sense of
existential connection between whatever
it is that you are and whatever you're
doing and the results of that there's
ways that people can manipulate that
there's ways that you can be thrown
around in the turmoil and buffeted by
the turbulence that is
the success or failure of whatever
you're getting into how good is the book
how many sub stacks
uh subscribers do you get all of that
stuff right
but
it wouldn't do for everybody to perhaps
exist in that way but it's certainly
pretty effective for some people
especially those that are trying to do
new things and build stuff
yeah no i i think you're spot on and i
think you know what we're getting at
here is you know i think in in this
world we often think of things as like
good or bad black and white
but it's the nuance of it is this great
thing this great obsession or passion
can fuel it's almost like rocket fuel
it can fuel you
in a number of different ways and some
of those might be good and some of those
might be bad it just kind of depends on
the context around it and to me
you know knowing that i have that
tendency or ability it's just making
sure in my life
and for myself i have those checks on
myself
so that i'm pointing things in the right
direction or that i'm not getting
obsessed or compulsive on the wrong
things like you said there you know the
book sales or the followers or the
subscribers all of those things which
you can especially if you have this
tendency you can drive yourself nuts on
and you can start assigning your value
uh as a human being being based on these
like numbers and things like that so
it's very important to set your life up
so that you have those checks and
balances and also things i think in your
life that keep you humble and grounded
so that you can you know use that wisdom
to use the stoic idea um because often
if you don't have that humility what
often happens is like you get blinded to
it and then that wisdom decreases and
then you find yourself doing crazy
things that you know you never wanted to
or should
you've been talking a lot about doing
hard things recently this is your
current obsession i guess
and
one of the very interesting
conversations that i had with joker
willing a few weeks ago on the show was
he has radical responsibility in extreme
ownership right like even if it's not
your even if it's not your fault it's
still your responsibility so he's
talking about the absolute maximum
amount of leaning into discomfort of
taking responsibility for stuff and i
mentioned to him that i i wondered
whether there would be such a thing as
taking too much responsibility where
people
put on their own shoulders
responsibility for things which they
were in no way responsible for they
weren't at fault for and it can actually
cause those kinds of people with that
type of mentality to be less effective
because they're it'll feed into
self-doubt it'll feed into imposter
syndrome it'll make them move more
slowly because they're terrified about
making decisions because they're going
to overthink things before they do that
and i wonder whether
doing hard things is similar to that as
well that at the moment it's very easy
to kind of point the finger at victim
culture look at all of these [ __ ]
snowflakes like you need to man up and
get after it and blah blah blah
and for maybe
the
widest area under the curve that might
be right that genuinely might be true
and i would
probably be tempted to say
yes for most of the normies that would
be true but when you apply that same
logic to people who already have a
disposition that causes them to be
type a go-getters that are
over-delivering and over-achieving and
over attempting
that can actually
be more of a negative and most of the
people that i know and a lot of the
people that i hang around with in austin
if i was to
if i was able to give them one skill it
wouldn't be the ability to work harder
it would be the ability to switch off
more
yeah no i i think that's um i think
you're spot on here and i think that's
again is why we need nuance on these
conversations and that's what i tried to
bring in this new book is that
you know doing hard things is is
important it's valuable obviously
but at the same point
for certain people it can get in the way
and the way i like to look at this is
looking at it through the sporting lens
and the lens of of choking and sport
what happens there well we know from
decades of research that the people who
tend to choke in sport are generally the
type a perfectionists who are incredibly
driven and what happens is for whatever
reason like that pressure that judgment
just kind of knocks them for a loop and
then what do they do they try to double
down work harder put more effort in to
force things and that backfires into
them having this negative doubt spiral
or this you know overthinking spiral
when the reality is they need to learn
how to let let go
to
you know care maybe a little bit less
and i underst i understand that sounds
sacrilegious in some avenues but i'll
give you an
example from an athlete um who i worked
with for for a while
is uh american distance runner uh sarah
hall
and before sarah hall
very good for a long time but never up
at the top upper echelon and then this
past year at the age of 38 set the
american record in the half marathon and
then recently went on to get fifth at
the world championships in the half
marathon or in the marathon excuse me so
phenomenal breakthrough late in life
and when you talk to her she says
i had to let go
i had to care a little bit less and
realize that win or lose
it wasn't me out there that was like you
know i'm not putting all of my
self-worth into running
win or lose
the people who love and support me are
still going to love and support me i'm
still going to work very hard but it's
not the only thing
in my life it's not the only thing that
defines me
and then she has this phenomenal
breakthrough and i think for people who
are those type a kind of pushers or
strivers extreme strivers what happens
is we can often get in our way and
actually the work i've done with elite
athletes especially is often to do just
that is how do i make sure that they
don't get in their way that they don't
like keep striving pushing etc another
you know the analogy that sometimes
helps to get this across to listeners
and and readers is
think of you know the the sprinter usain
bolt
if you watched him compete
he is again world record holder
greatest sprinter of all time you watch
him compete and he is trying to relax in
order to run his fastest
he is not trying to dig down grit his
teeth
you know whatever have you i'm sure he
does very hard things in practice
but when it comes to race day he knows
he's ready to perform and he knows to
put himself in that position he has to
let go relax when everything around him
is telling him to fight to push to do
all these things and i think that
analogy works for most uh most everyone
else who is in that kind of striver
pusher category
is this based then is the effective
strategy that
people whether they be high performers
in business technology
creativity sport
is it a case that you need to do a
little bit of introspection work out who
you are and then have the strategy that
comes in because
there will be somebody for whom
the
aggression heavy metal music before you
step out there
is the way to go it's also going to be
sport specific i wouldn't want a power
lifter to go out as relaxed as possible
you know it's a very different kind of
sport it's a very different kind of
pursuit uh podcasting for instance if
you were to go and do a huge podcast and
you're super nervous about it you want
to be as relaxed as possible because you
want to be able to have access to all of
that width that agility to be able to
move between your thoughts but again the
same might not be true if you're a
formula one driver perhaps i don't know
my point being that it's person specific
and it's domain specific exactly and i
think that introspection piece is really
important and actually what i found in
researching writing the book is that
the best performers tend to have this
internal sense of awareness
and self-awareness that that lower level
performers don't and that even goes with
understanding the emotional experience
and their thoughts and whatever inner
signals their body is sending in
preparation to do very difficult things
and this often runs counter to what we
teach people
especially in sport which is like hey
you know forget your doubts ignore your
emotions like push it away but the
reality is
that all provides feedback that we can
utilize to understand
what kind of state am i in versus what
kind of state do i want to be in and i
think the way i look at it is
are you prepared
for the demands that you're going to
face
and what kind of performance state
allows you to you know take on that task
you're spot on if i'm going to do you
know one rep of bench press or something
i want to be incredibly fired up
but for other
avenues i i don't and that's where we
get this idea
in sports psychology that they call it
the in this individual zone of optimal
functioning
which is for each individual in each
task you're going to need a different
level of physiological arousal and and
often a different level or type of like
emotional response
and here i think the the example of of
michael jordan is is perfect because
like he is known as this like hardcore
competitor
and if you know anything about jordan
the basketball player is he would almost
like create insults
out of things that people said in order
to fuel his fire
and for 99 of people this would be a
horrible strategy because we couldn't
handle it
because what would happen is it would
push us to playing out of a place of
like fear and low status and like anger
and mess up but because he's michael
jordan and his psychology was wired just
a very unique way
that actually fueled him
so again i think the self-awareness
piece is really important is you have to
figure out what works for you and your
type of uh you know individual
versus you know what you see on tv and
might work for somebody else dude he
nailed it i'm
very
having had you'll be episode 515 or
something of this podcast
and
blanket coverage this is the best way to
do things
statements
seem less and less true the more
episodes that i do
it's so
individualistic and i've learned this
with myself that there are times where i
need to be more fired up there are times
when i need to relax a little bit more
really cool example of this i got told
by a friend so tiger woods and rory
mcilroy were playing in a charity golf
game and they were partnered up with
ones with a comedian and the other ones
were the rock star or something like
normies normies maybe the normies play
golf but they don't play golf like tiger
woods or rory do but they were mic'd up
the whole time because it's for charity
and usually you don't get to hear what
the caddy and the golfer are saying to
each other especially as they're walking
down the fairway and
one of the guys said that he was
listening to what tiger and this dude
were talking about it's for charity
right
tiger and this guy are walking down and
tiger's coaching him on his swing he's
talking to him about the current weather
conditions he's saying that there's this
like issue that we're going to have to
get past so we might have to actually
use a slightly higher loft club in order
to be able to do the whatever whatever
talking to his guy then it cuts to rory
mcilroy rory mcilroy is explaining the
precise domino's order that he likes to
do like exactly what toppings he wants
so you have two
sports stars in the same event
that compete at a very similar sort of
level
with completely different mentalities
completely different headspaces while
they're doing the same thing so that's
what you said the individual
zone of optimal performance what was it
yep yep
that is
individual
because it relies on what is your
mentality what will work best for you
and then domain specific as well yeah i
love that
you know and it's it's funny there's
actually some interesting data it's
preliminary but it's fascinating that
shows that
part of the reason that is is because
people are sensitive to stress hormones
in different ways
so for some like that stress hormone
let's say cortisol goes up and someone
might like experience it x-fold maybe
because they have so many receptors for
it that they just like freak out
others
you know experience the same level of
stress hormone but it's just like it
doesn't hit you know it's not a big deal
so there's like underlying biology here
that tells us that it's really important
if you're that that sensitive person to
the stress hormone then you might need
to work really hard how to calm yourself
down because you only want like a little
hit of that
if your brain just you know isn't
sensitive it's like you know whatever
throw more stress hormones at us for
whatever reason then you might have to
like get fired up and like
find your way to get there or in
jordan's case like make it seem like you
know everybody's out to get you so that
you feel a little little something there
and i think that's that's what's so
important so to me what is what's the
takeaway there is like be open be aware
and then put yourself in different
situations and really try different
things to see what actually works
and you know take note of it and you can
really develop the skills to to do so
over a while man i
adore studies like that that come out
and show us interesting things so going
through this book doing your research
what were some of the other studies that
made your jaw hit the floor while you
were looking at uh insights around
toughness and resilience
yeah so there was i'll give you two that
were really fascinating to me is one was
a study of of they took expert
meditators and monks
and they compared you know the
meditators to normal people so normies
and they they took a very hot probe and
just put it on the wrist
okay so it was like very painful
well
the monks and the normal people had the
rated the same level of pain you know it
was like a seven or eight out of ten so
very painful they rated it the same but
in their brain
how it handled that pain was completely
different
so
before the painful probe was applied
the monks were just chill their brain
gave off nothing
the normal people
their pain reception was almost
preparing for the danger did they know
what was going to happen
they did they knew what was going to
happen they told them so it was they
could they knew the the probe was coming
so what happened is the
anticipatory response was sounding the
alarm okay
so they had this hyper response before
anything happened and then after the
probe was removed
what happened is the monks went back
down to zero the alarm got turned off
the pain perception went down to normal
again
the normal people it lingered it stayed
pretty high for a very long time and
what the researchers said is they said
you know the problem here is we have one
stressful stimulus
the monks are responding it to to that
only to me that message was how do we
respond to reality
which is the stressful thing itself and
don't let it linger or don't sweat in in
terms of anticipation
and in the monks kind of they went
through it in the book i go into more
details but it was really about like
accepting what you're gonna face
knowing that it might be painful but
that you have the tools to kind of work
your way through that and then when once
it's over having that ability that you
talked about earlier to switch off
and often we ne
neglect that last part
how much of a
role does confidence play here how big
of a contributing factor because what it
sounds like with each of these different
steps is
uh faith in self lack of self-doubt
conscious awareness that you have the
ability to overcome stuff like that what
what what have you learned about
confidence what it means what it is from
a sports science perspective
yeah it's it's huge it's absolutely huge
because confidence changes our
perception of how difficult something is
is it will actually change our
biological reaction or response
so for example if we are going into a
into a game
and we have actual inner confidence that
we're going to prep play well
our testosterone level tends to go up
and our cortisol stress hormones go down
if we're faking it and we're just trying
to say oh yeah i'm confident i got this
but there's like no substance or
evidence behind that and we don't
actually believe it the opposite occurs
testosterone doesn't budge cortisol goes
through the roof
so when we look at confidence the most
important thing i think is that
confidence needs evidence and that
evidence needs to be founded in doing
the work in some sort of reality
so your brain is almost smarter than
we'll call it your mind
in the sense that faking it only works
on really simple tasks that we could we
could do anyways so if would low stakes
tasks also contribute there as well
exactly low low stakes tasks all that
stuff um
but
in things that matter where the stakes
are at high and when something is on the
line
then like you need that inner confidence
that has to come from some sort of
evidence and the other part that i think
is really important here is we often
think confidence and we think certainty
it's not certainty it's confidence in
knowing
what the task is what the demands are
and then what are your capabilities
not necessarily i have the capabilities
to master this 100 percent but the
capabilities to know that win lose or
draw i can navigate through this thing
almost like those those monks
experiences they didn't know exactly how
painful it was
but they know i have the skills to
withstand some amount of pain i've
trained for this it will be okay
so
experience reality reflecting prediction
testing of the hypothesis around your
prediction and then a summary of what
happened whether it went well or badly
and then what your intuition around what
was going to happen and how accurate
that is but there is a threshold
different people have different amounts
of reality that they need to be given in
order for it to alter their own
self-image i imagine that some people
may have overconfidence and actually
takes a lot of negative experiences to
bring that down and the reverse happens
as well i think i'm perennially an under
confident person which means that i've
always felt
how would you say not triggered by
people with ego but i've always been
maybe a little bit jealous i've
certainly been jealous of some of my
friends that seem to have
undue confidence like yo you suck
you suck at this thing and you believe
that you're going to be good at it and
i can compare it to things that i know
that i would be good at and the fact
that i'm just completely riddled with
self-doubt around them so what's the
element there is that uh it's like a
psychological profile that's going on
where people need different amounts of
reality to come and tell them that
something's going to change
yeah no i think that that's spot on and
that's also mirrors what the psychology
shows us is that you know we essentially
craft our own stories we're like
storytellers
and you know just like a good writer
does like
you don't have all the details you
selectively get to internalize whatever
it is so some people tend to almost be
blinded or biased towards remembering
uh the good things that they did or the
successes they had and not everything
else negative that came along with it
and other people are the opposite right
and i think it's learning to work with
that a little bit and one of you know my
favorite examples from history actually
is someone who
you know displays this perfectly is the
america the former american president
abraham lincoln
who was like
this guy
who was if you read his letters he's
kind of like so pessimistic in the
moment he suffered with depression right
lifelong depression exactly lifelong
depression like just kind of a a sad guy
sad dude
but over the long haul
he had so much hope
meaning
i think we're going to win this war i
think we're going to put an end to
slavery all of this stuff but if you
just read his day-to-day communication
it's like all negative it's like the
world is ending
what are you doing like how what what
happened here and i think it was this
this
interesting balance of he figured out
how to
like
you know he wasn't a very confident
person he wasn't a glass half full type
person
and that allowed him to get through the
the day-to-day but somehow he cultivated
enough hope
that allowed him to persist in that long
enough to be able to you know obviously
succeed
very very interesting okay what was the
second study that blew your mind yeah so
the other one was the study in the nba
so on professional basketball players
and some psychologists what they did is
they
looked at the coaches behavior of all
these coaches who play or coach during
like a six year period of of of you know
in the nba
and then they looked at how their
players performed and they classified
the coaches they essentially classified
them in
terms of you know were you kind of a
players coach or were you on the
opposite end like this abusive
authoritarian style coach
and what they found
is that whenever a player played for
that authoritarian abusive style coach
their performance declined
and then their rate of technical fouls
and aggression increased
okay
but it wasn't during just
that season
that effect lasted for the rest of the
player's career
even when the coach was gone
so
what that told me or
you know the reason that blew my mind is
i'm thinking like oh of course it
impacts people when you're coached by
them
but just the lasting effect for the best
athletes on the planet that us coach for
a single season and then they move on to
someone who has a completely different
approach
can impact their play and then also
their level of aggression and vowels for
the rest of their career is kind of
mind-blowing and to me it tells you know
me
is with whoever i'm working with or if
you're a leader or coach or you're
managing people like your impact can
potentially last for a lifetime or a
career so like be very intentional on on
what you're communicating and what
you're showing that you value and and
how to do the things that you're doing
wasn't there a story about a texas a m
football team that
had some
it looked like their performance had
changed but it hadn't
yeah so this was one of my favorite
stories to tell i'm a native texan so
uh this is famous story in the u.s which
is
in the in the 1950s uh there's this
famous uh football coach college
football coach named paul bear bryant
and he took over the texas a m football
team and as the prop popular story goes
both in books and movies
is that he took all these players he
took them to the middle of nowhere texas
and he put him through this like
training camp from hell you know we all
have heard and experienced things you
know you just punish the players
and you weed out the ones who don't make
it
and the strong survive and the popular
story goes you know and it allowed them
to you know win championships and do
great things but what the story omits is
this is that season after the camp
the team was
one in nine so they sucked they were
horrible okay it was only three years
later i believe that they they had a a
very good season
but the couple years later when they had
a good season i think
out of you know the hundred or so
players that went to camp
only i think seven or eight players were
left
on the team you know a couple years
later so it wasn't the guys who went
through the camp from hell
and then the second thing on this story
that i think is really important is we
often think about this
you know when we put people through
difficult things and that it's like sink
or swim throw the eggs against the wall
see what ones you know don't break and
the ones who stick around they're the
toughest
well if you looked at the the
the accolades
of the players who decided to quit
like they were phenomenally talented
athletes one quit football and went over
to baseball and won a championship a
couple just said forget college football
i'm gonna go play in the nfl and they
made it you know a couple
were literally guys who quit and then
went on to become war heroes
and like you know captain and commanders
of like naval ships and airplanes and
all that that crazy stuff
and i think if you look at why they did
this and then what the research says
often people quit during difficult
things
not because they're not strong enough or
tough enough
but because they have the skills to do
something better
and to find them pla themselves a place
where they can thrive and utilize their
skills successfully
and the ones who stick it out aren't
necessarily tougher
they're actually just they're like you
know actually one of the football
players in that story put it put it best
and he said and i'm paraphrasing he said
essentially i had nothing better to do
it was either survive and go to college
and play football or go back home and
work in the fields which isn't what i
wanted to do so of course i was going to
stick around
people who have fewer other options are
actually going to be more boneheaded
when it comes to surviving difficulty
exactly
and i think we discount that so much
because we tend to again assign it to
our character
and have this negativity around maybe
quitting when sometimes quitting is just
like changing priorities
just like you did when you went from
cricket to oh i'm gonna start this
business it wasn't that you you know
quit cricket it was here's this other
thing that gets me really enthused that
i can pour my energy and motivation
towards that is probably more meaningful
in this moment and that was the right
decision and and you did it
there was a quote that i came across
last week that i've just been i haven't
been able to get out of my head around
you can be anything you want but you
can't be everything you want and
what we're talking about here is the
single thread of obsession that or hard
work or grit or determination or
conscientiousness or whatever
that is pulling somebody through all of
the different things that they do in
life
but they're not trying to do all of
those things at once and they're also
not trying to spread themselves too
thinly when they do it and this is
something that i wish
maybe that i'd realized earlier on
your highest point of contribution the
thing that you can do which contributes
the most to the world or your
progression or your growth or whatever
your goal is right now is
at most probably two things
realistically probably one thing
and in a world where we've been able to
put them on the moon and we can
amazon prime ourselves a brand new desk
seat without having to leave our house
it feels like we should have more
mastery and what people presume i think
is that they can just ratchet up their
productivity down regulate their sleep
improve their efficiency and i will be
able to fit more into my life but in
order to pick something up i think you
have to put something down for the most
part people are operating somewhere
close to their maximum capacity in any
case and one of the biggest lies about
productivity is that there are quick
fixes to being able to get more time
there are not it takes
so long for you to be able to open up
any more time because it is
arduous it is you reprogramming what
your presumptions are around your work
patterns or around doing pomodoro time
or around time blocking or whatever it
is that you end up doing my point being
that
your
capacity to work now
is what you should be working off you
can't add more stuff into your life
under the presumption that tomorrow
you'll just get more done like no no no
this is how much you have to get done
and then when you get more headroom
that's when you can add things in if you
choose to but
far more people than realize it are
trying to do three or four difficult
very difficult projects and make
progress at the same time you can't find
a wife by going out three nights a week
whilst being the leanest person you come
while saving a ton of money whilst
trying to go to the gym
you can't you pick a thing it doesn't
have to be a thing forever you can
periodize it right six months gonna get
in shape six months find a wife six
months do whatever it might take longer
it might take less time but
you can do that what you can't do is try
and do all of them at once because you
will make zero progress in any of them
it i i agree 100 i am a big fan and you
mentioned it there of periodizing your
life
is i think everybody gets this wrong
they're like oh i want to be balanced i
want to be balanced and that they often
think like that means everything all at
once
but balance to me
means periodizing so that i am choosing
the things that are important to me
absolutely
you're a serial monogamist with
obsessions
yeah yeah that that's what it is i love
that because that's that's what you're
doing and actually you know
when i've talked to world-class
performers for instance uh shalane
flanagan who won the new york city
marathon a couple years ago she said oh
i'm horribly in balance
but what i do is my family knows like
you know hey for this 12 weeks leading
up to this marathon like the marathon's
gonna kind of be a priority
but once that ends i'm shifting my focus
like husband you are back to being my
priority etc everybody else and we're
gonna shift those things around and
that's how people you know good people
get things done and it's the same here
like
i when i go into writing mode you know i
tell my wife hey like this is it i'm not
saying you're not important i love you
all this stuff but like i've really got
to get this done and and focus on this
and like i try and put constraints
around it and all that good stuff but
you you have to actively make that that
choice and i think where we go so wrong
is when we try and do everything all at
once and the modern world often like
sells us a fake story that telling us
that we can and if we go look around on
social media we actually we often think
that oh look at these people who are
great at everything but it's all it's
all a facade
you talk to really good performers as
you do all the time on this and you you
realize that
no they're they're really good at
prioritizing and then also i think with
that is having the self-awareness task
do i still want to be doing this thing
or do i want to shift my attention to
somewhere else and i think that's a very
important piece as well the
self-awareness
knowing
that something is about to come knowing
and having the trust to be able to
communicate to friends or family people
that you need support from people that
you need to be aware that you're not
going to be able to give them as much
support or whatever that's something
that has really only started to come up
very recently for me and i think a lot
about performance and and like assess
the way that i'm going about my life uh
but
all of these things i wonder
how much of them just come along for the
ride as a byproduct of getting older i
always think about this that how much of
the actual work that we put in and the
introspection and the self-development
how much of that would just be here
naturally because i'm now 34 and four
years ago i was 30. and four years
before that i was 20 so do you know what
i mean like that a lot of this stuff is
don't get me wrong i'm adamant that you
can design your life right you can
consciously have agency sovereignty you
can take control do all of that stuff
and it does have an impact but you can
also probably put too much pressure and
too much responsibility on your
shoulders and the people that are
listening to this show are definitely
going to be in that kind of a cohort uh
you're probably going to get the results
in life that you were meant to get in
any case because trying to stop yourself
from being as driven and conscientious
as you are would take an ungodly amount
of energy you can't stop yourself from
working as hard as you can and this is
the friends that i need to say if i
could give them any gift it would be to
be able to have an off day like that
that's what i would give to these people
but um
yeah i wonder how many of the insights
we really care about just come along for
the ride as a byproduct of of aging
yeah you know i think there is something
to that i remember you know i'm gonna
butcher this a little bit but there's
one theory of intelligence that is
essentially crystallized for fluid
intelligence
and you know i forget which is which but
it's essentially one is the things that
you your kind of capacity you have and
then the second is like that wisdom that
just develops and develops and has to
like you need age and time and
perspective to experience it the one
caveat on that i'd say is
i do think you have to be open and
willing to hear these lessons as you age
and gain this experience because i'm
sure you have and i i have as well you
know people in your life who you know
aren't as receptive to some of this
experience and wisdom that comes with
that that age and often it gets in their
way and often you look at them and
you're like you're still repeating your
20s over and over and over again
when you know and these other things are
hitting in your you in your head but
you're not receptive to it so i do think
like having maybe i don't know the
humility awareness like the ability the
introspective ability to like
listen to the lessons that life is
giving you is really vital i agree what
uh
what have we not said
about misconceptions that people have
around toughness and resilience what's
missing
yeah that's a great question i mean if
you want to know what's missing read the
book but in all seriousness i think the
other part of it is um
you know
we treat uh uh emotions wrong and i
hinted at this is where we're often told
you know don't listen to your feelings
emotions and thoughts and we're told to
like push away those negative thoughts
or that self-critic and often what
happens is that backfires and instead
what we want to do is like learn how to
accept navigate and experience them so
that we know the nuance between them
i'll give you a quick example on it on
emotions so
for example
um my wife is elementary school teacher
and uh for a while she taught
kindergarten in first grade so younger
kids
and i'd always ask her as like why do
kids throw tantrums and she's like they
all do
well think of it like a kid's experience
you experience this barrage of emotions
that you often have no idea where it
came from
and you freak out you throw a transform
because you don't know how to process it
and you ask the kid what's wrong and
she's like nine times out of ten they'll
tell you the same thing which is sadness
i'm sad
and sadness like that could come from
you know
uh getting pushed at the the playground
getting your pencils stolen not getting
selected for kickball it applies to
everything but as we grow and develop we
we create the nuance and understanding
that sadness could mean loneliness it
could mean jealousy it could mean like
all sorts of things
and to me like this toughness is about
developing that emotional skill and
intelligence and awareness
so that you can split apart okay is this
an emotion a feeling that i should
listen to
is it one i should pass on by is it one
that is giving me important information
like maybe like the feeling of
loneliness it is pushing and pro probing
me along to go like interact with
another human being and create
connections so that i don't feel this
and i think that ability to again sit
with experience those emotions and
develop that nuance is vital and often
goes against the common you know advice
to like just ignore everything and push
through yes so
ethan cross who
is one of the world's leaders when it
comes to managing your inner voice and
having a better relationship with that
you know you'll you'll be aware of this
is distancing you know talking to
yourself in the third person giving
yourself advice as you would to a friend
those for me are really really good
tools and if you think about what
mindfulness is mindfulness is
noticing a sensation arise
noticing that it's arisen and letting it
go it's the noticing bit right it's the
mindfulness gap it's not being swept up
in the thought it's noticing that you
and the thought are separate it's
noticing that you are not to the emotion
you and the emotion are separate rogan
said on monday he was saying uh
people often confuse their thoughts with
themselves he's like you're not your
thoughts your thoughts are just passing
through that they are the weather and
you are the sky they're a state that
you're in currently sometimes it's great
sometimes it's a bit shitty but it's
just passing through and the point is to
be able to distinguish between the two
and also to be able to notice when
there's weather
exactly and i think you know that's
actually how i look at and define
toughness is like how do we create that
space
because if you can create that space and
realize that you're not your thoughts
and there's a little gap there or that
you know your emotions are messengers
but they're not dictators right if you
have that space then you can deal with
the difficult moment
if you don't have that space and it
collapses what often happens is we have
that negative thought and then we jump
straight towards like disaster spiraling
rumination can't get it out of our head
so to me is you know just like that
mindfulness is like how do we create
that space and some of those tools as
you said ethan cross does a great job
elaborating on as well is like
anything that creates that that
perspective that distance allows us to
deal with things a lot better steve
magnus ladies and gentlemen if people
want to check out your work and get the
book and see everything else that you do
where should they go
yeah so you can find me all on social
media at steve magnus twitter instagram
all those places and then my website is
stevemagnus.com dude i appreciate you
thank you
yeah thanks a lot for having me what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you